[Applause]
[Music]
one of the first lessons that they
teach you are giving you a small very
simple
mission in which you pretend to be
someone else
i was in the street and my instructor
showed me
a passing taxi they told me see the
number of the taxi i said yes
i said okay taxi disappeared and he told
me
in two hours you meet me at this in this
corner
and you bring me the name and the
address of the taxi driver
and of course i could not use the
internet of course no police no official
office because i i was supposed to
pretend
i'm a tourist and i thought what will i
what should i do
so i started to go from one taxi station
to the other
asking people if they know this in this
car but
this is this number and uh because i
forgot something it is very important
that i
find this taxi driver because i forgot
something in his car
so they start calling each other finding
out and then there was another helpful
guy
who was willing to take me to the house
of
this taxi driver which he did and i
fulfilled my mission i was the only one
from the people who were in training
with me
who brought the information back
[Applause]
when you want to recruit someone for an
undercover mission
you're looking for certain traits first
of all is the ability to play act
and to impersonate someone else if you
don't have that then
all the rest is immaterial after that
and if you have to work undercover in an
enemy country your cover has to be
perfect
when people suspect you it can become
very unpleasant and very dangerous
and you have to have an identity of a
real person
a person that is living somewhere with a
real name
with real history and this is the life
that you
learn you pretend to be that person and
then
of course you add some other things and
other traits because
it has to suit you so you go to the
place where this person is supposed to
live
you learn the area you live there for a
while you take a room in a hotel let's
say
and every day you walk to a different
place until you feel that you know the
area
very well because this person is
supposed to have been
raised there so you learn as much as
possible and when you don't know a
detail
you find in the area a detail that is
good enough for it
for instance you don't know exactly the
school they went to but there is a
school in the area so
this is the school you mentioned when
you are being asked
you really have to to believe that you
are this other
other person
[Music]
one very important thing to act while
being interrogated is never be
aggressive never be conceited
never show that you are too sure of
yourself
a be humble be nice be friendly
be naive even pretend to not understand
too much
and act natural towards the situation as
if it was something
completely natural that everybody else
is is going through
and if he starts to like you because
you're nice
and maybe if he can feel even sorry for
you that you're
maybe a bit scared or frightened and
then he's on your side
he does not want to break you you have
to really
to act very carefully so it's not to
bring him to a place where he wants to
show you
who is the stronger of the two
whenever you go into a place into a
store or something you are all the time
watching for escape routes just in case
it becomes part of your nature like uh
like noticing
people around you noticing who's
watching you who is talking to you you
just
you're more alert than people usually
are
if force comes to worse you have an
escape plan
of course you have a set of clothes that
are completely different you change your
appearance
you change your papers and you take a
car and you cross the border
or you have an aircraft coming to rescue
you
or you go out to sea and wait for to
being rescued
or you are helped by another agency
in the area who smuggle you out of the
country there are many different ways to
do that
you're always prepared to grab your
things
the bare necessities that you need for
this and just
disappear from the area
you